Ford is getting back into the luxury car
drivers seat today the automaker
unveiled plans to revive its lagging
Lincoln brand with the new Continental
concept a full-size sedan coming next
year that looks the business here to
discuss the new direction for Lincoln is
mark fields Ford CEO and president
thanks for joining us thanks for coming
in here thanks pretty exciting I mean
this Continental is a real break from
the rest of Lincoln design language I
wonder what you're going for here is
this a halo car is this like a Maybach
type luxury car or is this the kind of
thing that even I could possibly afford
one day I mean what are we looking at
well when you think about it
Lincoln for us we're absolutely
dedicated the Lincoln is a world-class
luxury brand and a client experience to
match its core to our growth plan as a
company we laid out a plan a couple of
years ago we said we introduced four new
vehicles in four years this is the
fourth vehicle a full-size sedan and
when you think about the Continental
concept continent it has a meaningful
name and it symbolizes our past the best
of Lincoln sedans so where we are on the
journey with Lincoln and we know we're
on a journey over a number of years this
is gonna be our flagship is this the
other three though have already been
built on existing platforms is this a
completely new platform here this car
well we're just showing the concept
right now we'll talk about more
technical details as we get towards the
production vehicle which will be in the
marketplace so things can still change
no everything set will you not have
suicide doors can I just make that one
request that we get suicide doors in the
back you know it's really interesting if
you look back in the history of the
Continental the First Continental was
designed by Edsel Ford and Edsel was all
about a beautiful design and it has
always epitomized in the 50s and 60s the
Continental really epitomized the beauty
of full-size sedans the we did have a
period of time in the early 60s where we
had the suicide doors and I guess our
lawyers won't allow us to say those
things they won't allow you to use like
words but you could still use the doors
that open backwards but it was you know
that was that was for a short period but
it was very recognizable but clearly
when you look at this vehicle we
really wanted to signify what we call
quiet luxury which is all about elegance
it's about effortless power and it's
around a serene and relaxing interior
place to qohen chill if you like alright
so elegant is a place to chill how much
of this that mark is about China because
you guys have done a lot of research
there and you're in some ways are you
targeting the Chinese market well China
is an important market the good news is
we've been growing the Lincoln brand
globally here in the US for example last
year we grew twice more than twice the
industry average in terms of the luxury
industry we launched the brand in China
last fall and is really interesting we
did a lot of research in China and and
our awareness is very high there because
Chinese consumers remember Lincoln as
presidential cars and you had Gable and
Elizabeth Taylor etc president ken so
and you know he was he was in the car
when he was in Dallas that day but since
we launched it in the in the fall it's
exceeded our sales expectations so when
we were researching this car what we
found between North America the US and
China there's a lot more similarities
than differences in terms of what
consumers want one of the big difference
is this full-size luxury sedan in China
you usually driven you have a chauffeur
so the backseat amenities are really
important and that's why you see in this
concept this continental concept we
spend a lot of time in the rear of the
vehicle to make sure it's comfortable as
privacy gives you that opportunity to
relax
but we'll be offering the same vehicle
in both market biggest market that China
when you look at the segment the
full-size luxury segment right now
the biggest market in the world for that
is China it's still fairly substantial
here in the US it's about it's it's it's
been about stable over the last number
of years but it's growing in China that
segment alone last year was up 17% and
you're opening up a ton of new
dealerships there and it's been a
booming market for Ford in general
I love the blue interior here I'd say
I'm a special kind of consumer maybe but
everyone I've been talking to today has
been just praying for one thing and
that's rear-wheel drive or all-wheel
drive as opposed to a friend wheel drive
you only have I think Mustang and f-150
on a rear-wheel drive platform what
about this well I mean that ignition
yeah we're we're not at this not talking
about architectures and I know you're
really cool but you know we take it from
a consumer standpoint and where we're
targeting this vehicle in terms of the
ride characteristics in terms of this
elegance and this effortless power and
this serene and relaxing interior what
we're having our engineers focus on is
delivering that regardless of what the
architecture it sits on because as long
as you can deliver that that's true to
your brand customers don't care they're
not saying well I'm not only gonna look
at this vehicle because it's real wheel
drive or front wheel drive or all-wheel
drive they want it to fit what they
would their their their wants and needs
so we're gonna continue to do that with
Lincoln it looks like you're targeting
more rolls-royce and Bentley than the
Germans in any case all of those
countries all those companies operate in
countries where they don't have to use
the dollar is it a weakness right now
for you guys well when you look at the
strength of the dollar first we have to
put into perspective when the dollar is
strong it means that the US economy is
strong and this is our largest market
and our most profitable so that's good
news for us the same token it does erode
our a competitive price position
particularly versus competitors who are
importing vehicles so when you stand
back it is a net negative for us but
we're gonna deal with whatever the
business environment throws at us so
we'll continue first and foremost to
focus on bringing up really compelling
products in the marketplace work on our
cost structure work on our cost
efficiency scale efficiencies get the
cost down and our vehicle still provide
that value to consumers but this is the
environment we're in right now it
doesn't doesn't it allow you I mean John
Krajcik from TrueCar has written a story
about the fact that it allows you to
really beef up the interior you can put
better components because you can afford
to buy more of that stuff than your
competitors can well it depends on where
those components are coming from and
obviously as a global OEM I mean
manufacture we have parts that are
domestically produced for our vehicles
that are domestically assembled here
we're very impart some the outside but
overall we're just you know are the way
we run the businesses we look at the
business environment
every week as a team and we deal with it
and right now we have a strong dollar
environment overall it's a net negative
but there's some positives in there
given that the US economy is strong what
about the lower oil prices and energy
prices is that changing any of your
longer-term thinking in terms of
development well when you look at
consumers these days no matter what the
price of gas is fuel economy is still
one of their most important purchase
criteria because they remember you know
four or five years ago when gas was four
four fifty gallon and they had to park
their vehicles we are seeing we're not
seeing a correlation where it's low gas
prices so the industry is going to go up
we've never seen that in the past but
what we have seen is the types of
vehicles that consumer wants so we are
seeing consumers favor now more small
medium and large size SUVs and as a
company we have a full family of
vehicles so we're there for them but
even in those vehicles they want the
very best fuel economy does it change
though your longer-term thinking in
terms of where energy prices might be
going and how you guys might do
development if our longer-term thinking
continues to be listen it's a
non-renewable resource so our view is
the price of a gallon of gas or barrel
oil will go up over time and that's why
we're spending so much time on
delivering customers the best fuel
economy that we can and being among the
best or the best in each segment let me
just get back to Lincoln first I can ask
about your investment two and a billion
dollars over four models as being the
fourth Cadillac has said it's going to
put 12 billion dollars into developing
that brand obviously that's on a forward
basis and you're looking at stuff that
you've done here what do you what do you
think as far as throwing numbers at this
well I think when you when you look at
our journey that we're on with like a
where we are on the journey we think
that's appropriate amount now keep in
mind that's just capex that's just our
capital expenditures doesn't include
things like launch and advertising and
things of that McConaughey's paycheck
exactly and that's a good thing we have
a new marketing metric which is how many
times your ads get spoofed so it's been
pretty successful but we think that's an
appropriate amount for where we want
ahead with like and keep this in mind
that we're not the biggest we're one of
the smallest so how are we using that to
advantage giving customers personalized
service and if you look at China for
example the way we've developed our
dealerships when you walk into a
dealership in China it's like walking
into somebody's high-end living room
that's the kind of personalized service
we want to use to differentiate Lincoln
along with really compelling elegant
doesn't when do you think I'm gonna be
able to get what you would consider the
ideal Lincoln experience when can I walk
into a dealership be treated the way you
want me to be treated and buy the car
that you want me to buy well we have a
number of dealers our top dealers today
are delivering that cup of course but I
mean the end game when is that there's
no there's never an end game no because
when you look at technology and the
technology enablers that are really
enabling great retail experiences that's
never going to stop so for us as Lincoln
we want to keep pushing the envelope in
a way that makes customers lives easier
and we're having our engineers and our
marketers focusing on experiences first
and then how does technology enable that
experience